are you doing a few things every day
that your ancestors would have done what
250 000 years ago oliver berkman he's a
journalist a writer and one of the
greatest thinkers i've had the pleasure
of sitting with here on this podcast
people talk all the time about the
importance of learning to say no right
there's a subtext there they think what
that means is if you just learn to say
no to all the stuff you don't want to do
you can spend your time doing stuff you
do want to do way harder than that you
have to say no to things that you do
want to do we are
wired for racing through things all of
us who are sort of moving at this speed
need to experiment a little bit with
like what it feels like to just slow
down to the speed that things take
any action that actually brings things
into the world involves a confrontation
with your limitations getting through
that discomfort to what lies on the
other side is so empowering without
further ado i'm stephen bartlett and
this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
as a journalist um
i was quite surprised to read some of
the articles you'd written and the
subject matter wasn't necessarily like
always about the news or what's going on
or it wasn't gossipy it was quite
i don't know existential and deep and
about regret and life and happiness and
these kinds of things why did the desire
to talk about and to write and research
those topics come from a new
that's a good question i mean i think
early early when i was a journalist i
was doing whatever i needed to do and a
lot of that was kind of news
more newsy but i've always wanted to try
to bring into that kind of daily context
these big
serious ideas and i think it's just
because
i'm fascinated by them and i think i'm
fascinated by them because i on some
level struggle with them right i mean i
don't think anyone if they're honest
writes about happiness who
is just
completely happy all the time because
then that topic is boring to that person
i think i'm probably a pretty anxious
person going back less so now uh having
spent years kind of
therapising myself in public in in the
in columns and books but um
that sense that you sort of need to find
some secret to address
your own issues and also when it comes
to sort of productivity and time
management and all those topics it's
like
maybe if i could find the system that
would put me in total control of my time
then maybe i wouldn't need to feel
worried about the future and you know
things like that we're all just sort of
revealing our deepest
uh issues in the things we choose to
focus on and write about you alluded to
it a little bit there but you said you
know one of the books you wrote was
called the antidote happiness for people
who can't stand positive thinking
interesting title what was the
inspiration but i mean you said
struggling with unhappiness was was i
mean by the time i wrote that i was sort
of i'd given all these things a lot of
thought i'd written this column for the
guardian for quite a few years and i
sort of noticed this pattern emerging
in the in the approaches and the
philosophies that really seemed to do
something for me and to sort of um lift
my spirits help me navigate the world a
bit more more calmly and effectively and
they were not
uh
what i call in that book positive
thinking right they were not
fill your mind with upbeat thoughts and
set incredibly ambitious goals and try
to push yourself relentlessly towards
achieving them it was actually
much more to do with being open to
negative stuff and being willing to feel
anxiety and security uncertainty and the
potential for failure and all those
things
it's actually a much more resilient way
to um
to be in the world i think plus it i
guess it's kind of
it's the contribution that i can make to
the world of self-help and things like
that is to bring my kind of
pessimistic slightly sardonic i don't
know british northern i don't know where
this comes from culturally really but
like
of a of a field like the self-help
industry like
just so much of this is rubbish and at
the same time
the topic that this is ultimately about
is really important and you can't just
dismiss it completely so um what would
you say are some of the big sort of
central misconceptions about how to
become happy or
what is it that fundamentally makes us
unhappy i sat here with moe gowda who
wrote a book about happiness um
the happiness equation and he talks a
lot about expectation management when
your expectations are too high and if
your expectations go unmet then we're
unhappy um and you know in a lot of your
writings you talk about
being a bit more
aware that any lack of productivity or
hardship or struggle isn't a sign of our
inadequacy as humans it's very much
the nature of earth yeah full life i
guess
i mean yeah in terms of misconceptions i
think that the sort of fundamental one
that i was writing about in that earlier
book is
is the idea that happiness is best
achieved by aiming for happiness you
know that setting out in your life to
get happy
is
there's something amiss with this notion
right happiness is the kind of thing
that seems to arise as a byproduct of
certain kinds of meaningful activity but
if you make it the
sort of goal of your life you can sort
of bear down on it too much and then it
sort of
goes away the book on some level is
about
um
turning your attention away from
happiness and finding happiness that way
through sort of the pursuit of
reality right through engaging in
meaningful activities and we can talk
about what meaningful means i suppose
but but not but not sort of what will
make me feel better or best as the
as the as the sort of navigation aid
that you use in life and then happiness
coming as a as a sort of a secondary
effect of that i think you know
the the the sort of crassus kind of
positive thinking fails just because the
human mind
does not work like that if what if you
decide that you're always going to fill
your mind with
positive upbeat optimistic thoughts
then every negative thought that creeps
in is like a new failure and something
to feel stressed about and something to
try to stamp out
and uh
that's just sort of not true to the
situation of like who we are which is a
big mixture of all sorts of feelings so
if we're not aiming for happiness then
and we're aiming for kind of demeaning
meaningful activities in the process
what are those what have you come to
learn are the meaningful activities that
end up creating the byproduct of
happiness
i mean it's the question and i don't
think i've like come to the final answer
in in any of this but um
i think meaning
it's it's a really
fascinating idea because i think people
know
in a sort of intuitive way whether what
they're doing is meaningful there's a
question that i write about that comes
from a psychotherapist called james
hollis whose work has been really uh um
had a real big impact on me which is to
ask of a choice or of a life path that
you might be on whether it's enlarging
you or diminishing you
and
i don't think this language works for
everybody but for me it's like oh okay
you can tell that there are times when
life is not enjoyable
but it's about growth what you're doing
it's like it's good that you're doing it
and it's meaningful that you're doing it
and then there are times when life might
be perfectly fun
but if you really stop and think about
it it's like it's missing the point
somehow i think one the sort of an acute
example of this that most people will
have experience of is
if like a friend or a relation of yours
is going through a crisis and you're
helping them out in some way you're
there to just as some company or i i
recall one example when some friends of
mine were going through a really awful
thing and i was like literally like
doing the dry cleaning for them right it
was just like they just needed help in
this kind of way and you have that
feeling of like
i'm in the right place here this is
there isn't something else i ought to be
doing now doesn't mean it's fun because
the whole situation is awful doesn't
mean it's in great activity because
doing someone's dry cleaning is not
necessarily a great activity but but you
know that you're in the right place and
i think that we can hope to have that
feeling about quite a lot of the sort of
work and
other things that we do in in non-crisis
moments so that's how i kind of think
about that this is a good use of this
day of your
very limited time on the planet one of
the things that i view that seems to be
pretty correct
um when i'm trying to figure out what is
meaningful it makes me gives me that
feeling of like fulfillment that i'm in
the right place as you describe it is
when i look back at like the human
struggle over thousands of years and
really what made us survive it tends to
be the case that i feel best when i'm
doing the things that are kind of in
line with how my ancestors lived
right so i mean on one hand you could
say
eating certain things and drinking and
sleeping but then as we kind of
described it there which is like banding
together and collaborating ultimately
that's central to how why we're here and
so it's conceivable that our ancestors
might have left that message in my
genetic code to say stephen not only are
you going to struggle forward but you're
going to do it together yeah and so when
you helped your friend with their dry
cleaning that was a really human
historically like human act of banding
together and support
um but i i feel like we've kind of lost
track of those fundamental human
things if that makes sense and whenever
we do them now which is like helping
each other
you know eating stuff that's grown from
the ground
the over stimulation of dig like digital
items and screens in our lives
loneliness these are all callings to
kind of get back to our tribe and in
fact i i'm coming to learn despite what
the happiness industry sells you it
actually might be really really
fundamentally simple in a in a way which
is trying to be more human
yeah yeah i've heard yeah that's such a
good point i've heard somebody
express this as like you should ask are
you doing a few things every day
that your ancestors would have done what
250 000 years ago exercise right
being together in our tribes right being
outdoors
outdoors right the studies and being
outdoors are really startling and i
think the problem is so many of us now i
mean uh
writers are the sort of ultimate example
but but but so many of us you for sure
like we're doing what we're mainly doing
with our days is manipulating symbols in
one way or another right images words
ideas all day long
like and
and a lot of these things are so new
like writing is is incredibly modern
invention on the evolutionary uh time
scale let alone podcasting and um this
is a sort of very low grade productivity
idea that i've written about and i think
is really important is to to try to
think about anything you're doing in
terms of physical actions and physical
next actions and so one thing i do when
i'm writing for example is i sort of set
goals that are to do with creating
physical documents right i'm going to do
this i'm going to write this i'm going
to print it out and it's going to have
something on my desk the hole in my
hands that i did today it's very easy to
get lost in that in that world that
doesn't have
like hard edges that doesn't have a
physicality in it and it's very alluring
because it feels kind of
you feel sort of god-like in that world
if you spend all day sort of with your
head mainly occupying
cyberspace or the metaverse but but yeah
you miss out on that essentially human
stuff that you're talking about and in
your new book you talk a lot about kind
of stripping back a lot of this [ __ ]
that has consumed our lives and the
complexity and these narratives which
have been kind of sold by the happiness
and efficiency and procrastination
industry let's call it um your new book
4000 weeks time and how to use it which
i found
incredibly important i think that's the
best way to describe it so i really want
to go through a couple of the points in
the book that i
i found compelling and that i wanted to
ask you questions on the first is
chapter one which was the limit of um
the limit embracing life
um and you talk about this concept of
embracing our limits what did you mean
by that seems to me and it's certainly
my experience but i think it is more
universal than just like my my issues
seems to me that a lot of what we do
uh the way we behave in the world and
the way we try to manage our time
especially
it's all really
based around trying to avoid
confronting something about our
situation
it's a kind of an emotional avoidance
it's to avoid feeling what it is like to
be
who we are which is finite human beings
right four thousand weeks the title
refers to the approximate length of uh
average lifespan in the west um which is
terrifying by the way this is terrifying
yeah yeah i love that
i thought
the risky decision i realized in
hindsight to give the book this title
because it might just cause people to
like run away from the bookshop and not
buy the book but anyway the um
so we're very finite in our amount of
time we're obviously finite on the daily
level of the amount of time we have but
also finite in how much control we can
exert over it right you nobody knows
what's happening in the very next moment
you can you can take actions to increase
the likelihood that what you want is
going to happen but we're all totally
sort of vulnerable to events and to
every
to every moment it's increasingly
impossible to have sort of complete
knowledge about anything that you're
doing or any sphere in which you're
acting and then you know relationships
just inherently involve you know
romantic relationships but all
relationships it just inherently
involves this kind of
vulnerability to other people and and
things they might do to hurt you or
think bad things that might happen to
them that would cause you to suffer and
so we're in this kind of very very
limited
situation and the i guess the main
argument in my book is that like if we
followed through the ramifications of
that we would use our time in a in a
somewhat different way
and actually i think a more relaxing way
i don't think it's a kind of recipe for
stress although the title is probably a
recipe for stress but um
in productivity for example the quest to
try to do everything to become like
limitlessly optimized so that you can
handle all your incoming email you can
pursue all your ambitions and business
ventures you can meet all the
obligations you feel from your family
and friends or from society and do it
all that's trying to become unlimited
right that's trying to become limitless
um
and we there are lots of other examples
of this
where i think what we're really doing is
is just trying to avoid feeling our
finitude
and some people want to say well isn't
it great to believe that we're limitless
because then you can like do astonishing
things and i want to say
no i think the kind of limitation i'm
talking about
confronting it and feeling it and living
into it is actually the precondition of
doing
the the most sort of extraordinary
things with a life because
you get to kind of give up on this
impossible quest to
fit yourself to every expectation that
the world might have one in which you
can only fail right and just focus on
doing that right yeah inadequate yeah
and and the sort of great inventors and
the great entrepreneurs of today and the
great sort of historical
figures like all these people they
didn't
they did things that people thought were
previously thought were impossible yeah
but they didn't um they very very
deliberately understood that using their
time the way they wanted to use it meant
sacrifices
um it meant neglecting things that would
be completely good things to do right
i'm sure you know what i'm talking about
here right i mean it's like you there
are 25
things you could do it's not that only
one of them is any good like
24 of them are good but even so most of
them are gonna have to you're gonna have
to be able to withstand the anxiety of
just neglecting most of them in order to
focus on and fundamentally
you believe which i also completely
agree with which is in fact why i have
this sand timer here which i just picked
off my desk before we started recording
you believe that um people do go through
life
not almost i don't for me it's like not
realizing slash not believing that they
will die it's almost like humans aren't
able to understand the concept of
infinity and they're also not able to
understand the concept of finality right
the fact that we will i will come to an
end so we don't live in such a way we
don't live with such a belief and if you
look at a lot of the decisions i make
you would assert that i'm living like i
think i'm going to live forever right
because my my misprioritization of
things that actually clearly matter more
and this kind of constant difference of
happiness to the future i will be happy
when right and then we live in you know
because one of the things i say and i
say this on my live show is
i say to the audience that
if you think about it
probably about 90 of this audience are
currently living in a way in which a
previous self of them told themselves if
they got here they would be happy right
yes but their current self is saying
not now we'll be happy when so deferring
it going into the future yeah so people
don't live like they know they're gonna
die essentially right and i think you
know something that's important to say
about that is like i think that that
that mindset i've i've seen it called
and i refer to in the book is like when
i finally mindset right it's like when
something happens then the moment of
truth is going to come and after that
life is going to be fulfilling and easy
but not yet i mean it's obviously as you
say it's totally like drains the meaning
out of life in the present but it serves
again it serves this purpose of
avoidance right because if you're always
storing up fulfillment for the future
you don't have to acknowledge the fact
that like this is it life isn't a dress
rehearsal like you've got to do things
now if you're ever going to do them
there's a great quote from john maynard
keynes the economist that i
use in there about how people who live
in this mindset and he's talking about
pretty much everyone really um they're
trying to secure for their actions i
won't get this exactly right they're
trying to secure for their actions of
spurious and delusive immortality by
always pushing them into the future
right so the man who thinks like this
keynes writes uh doesn't doesn't love
his cat but only his cat's kittens and
not really their kittens but the kittens
kittens and so on forever right and so
the downside
is that you never get to enjoy and value
and find fulfillment in life now but the
upside is it sort of helps you feel like
you might be going to live forever it's
kind of useful to be putting things off
because it it
it helps this act of denial that we're
all engaged in it also means that we
continue as humans to struggle forward
right we continue to take on struggle
whether it's challenge or ambition we
continue to be ambitious and then i go
well maybe that's also what allowed our
ancestors to give give birth to us
because if our ancestors weren't
trying to build a better tomorrow and
kind of deferring gratitude to the to
the empire that they were trying to
build then maybe we wouldn't be here so
is it a human
thing to also kind of defer our
happiness to the future i think it must
be and really is and i think we are sort
of goal seeking
organisms i think it's hugely compounded
by
the culture in which we live in the
economic system
in which we live and i think it's sort
of gone uh into warp speed in a way that
we could
step back from but i also think that
it's not about giving up goals right
it's not about stopping trying to
achieve things in the future it's about
it's about not investing the whole value
of what you're doing
in those in those future
outcomes you can't build anything a
relationship business
creative work you can't do it unless you
are partly focused on on where you're on
where you're going but you don't have to
be
exclusively focused on where you're
going and i would say you probably
shouldn't be exclusively focused on
where you're going because it will
damage the
product that you're creating as well so
you might fall into the efficiency trap
as you call it which is chapter two
right you get you get completely fixated
on valuing the the present only in terms
of how it um is going to help uh uh
create the the future thing and then you
find what happens is that
actually you get further and further
away from achieving that thing because
you in trying to make yourself more
efficient in trying to sort of
process more and more tasks to get
closer to your goal
you make yourself more efficient and
then more and more tasks like flood in
to fill the excess capacity and this is
parkinson's law and a whole lot of other
kind of it goes by a whole lot of names
but it's this idea that um
yeah if you if all you do is make
yourself more efficient
then you'll just be dealing with a
greater incoming volume of things and
inbox zero i felt was the perfect
example of that in your book where the
better you get at sending emails and
replying fast in fact the more replies
you get and people come to know you as
having a reputation of he emails back
quickly which is going to get even more
emails and then the challenge of getting
to inbox zero becomes increasingly
harder and then you find yourself
drowning
yeah absolutely right and it's just when
you spell it out like that it's like of
course and so you know i remember when i
was um
a young journalist sort of feeling
overwhelmed by the number of articles i
was being asked to write so you get
really really better at
writing them really fast and you get a
reputation for
being able to
write quite a long complicated article
in a short amount of time like who's the
editor going to ask when the next one
comes up right i mean and you know i got
a lot of benefit from being the person
that the editor asked but it certainly
didn't make me less busy yeah i think i
have that a bit with my pa at the moment
she i've got a reputation with her being
able to do
50 meetings a day right so my calendar
is now 50 meetings a day and we've
actually forgotten about the concept of
like i need to eat at some point
so like there's no i looked at my
calendar the other day she's superb and
in fact she does exactly what i've
always done to do so she's not at fault
here i am but i looked at my calendar
the other day and i was with her in the
car and i go isn't it funny it's like
every minute of the next 14 hours is
scheduled but i but there's no space for
lunch or just like
sending a voice in it to my girlfriend
right so i've kind of like
misprioritized my life but again it's
because i've i've con i've i've not
fought back against that by being
successful at being efficient i've
you know brought more efficiency into my
life and taken away
things that give me meaning like
connecting with my girlfriend or my
mother or my family or you know those
passions and
and i think yeah i mean i'd be
interested to know if this resonates
with you for me when i've got into that
kind of groove that place where you're
sort of pursuing efficiency
at the expense of everything else for me
anyway part of what's going on is was
always to do with self-worth right it's
this idea that you've got to get to this
point where you are this optimal and
this efficient and productive
that you
wouldn't really be justifying your
existence on the planet somehow if you
if you if you didn't do all these things
and so i think lots and lots of people
who sort of accomplish stuff
are driven to accomplish stuff because
they feel like they need to accomplish
stuff like it's not okay if they if they
don't uh accomplish stuff and so
that is a kind of never-ending treadmill
as well because um
like why are you going to decide that
any particular given level of output or
accomplishment is the one where you can
where you can
relax and i think
one of the things i'm always at pains to
try to get across talking about this
book is that um
this is meant to be a relaxing message
right i think this is a liberating
message that can be like a weight off
your shoulders because if you
if you see that what you were doing was
trying to do an impossible amount in
order to feel
like okay about yourself on some deep
buried level
well if you really begin to internalize
that it's impossible
then it can't be what you need to do in
order to feel okay about yourself maybe
you're okay already and then the things
that you do in the world are kind of
extra and then i think you know the
message of our being finite the message
of our of our being limited is not so
now you've got to like squeeze value out
of every moment and
go base jumping every weekend or
something otherwise have you really
lived it's much more like okay oh great
the pressure's off
i can't do an impossible amount
i can only do a few of the things that
seem like they matter
so all i need to do is
choose for now which ones seem the most
important and
focus on them and give my energy to them
and it's much more doable i can
completely relate to that attachment of
efficiency to self-worth it felt so it
felt like you were calling me out
and the other thing i have which i just
realized as you were saying was
because i've become successful in the
eyes of society quote unquote
i'm now also trying to live up to my own
external reputation that people have of
me people say oh steve you're
you never sleep you're so
you work so hard
so when i have days where i don't work
really hard and i clearly just achieved
nothing that day
i'm like haunted by the my almost my
reputation right which is largely false
my reputation that i don't sleep and
that i'm working all the time and that
i'm super productive and that i'm
organized and i don't procrastinate i'll
tell you now it is a load of [ __ ]
i
some days i do like
a lot of a lot of days i do way less
than the people around me right but i
have this so but i do have those moments
now where if i have like an unproductive
day
or
i've like slept until midday for
whatever reason which happens a lot by
the way or i've procrastinated which
happens every day or i'm really
unproductive i go
you're not being steve bartlett you're
you're a fella you're letting down your
reputation right you're a fraud
you are a fraud i get that a lot that
feeling of like it doesn't like [ __ ]
me but that feeling of oh i if i look at
today and i look at the reputation of
stephen butler i am a fraud
um it's fascinating i think it must be
it's a lot it's a lot worse with a high
public profile but i do think it's kind
of almost
a universal trait that a lot of people
have a lot of people who are sort of
well thinking back we've talked before
about like b i was just a sort of your
garden variety high achiever at school
right like the kid getting the a grades
or whatever and and
and
a lot of people in that situation
have what is called in psychology
probably know like they have a fixed
mindset rather than a growth mindset
right so one of the consequences of this
is every time you do well
it's not something to be happy about
because you did well it's like something
to feel pressure about because now
that's the bar that you've got to reach
next time and it's like you know it's
suddenly your your success has become
this um
this standard that you've now got to
meet every single time in the future and
that is like
it's
it's it's a agonizing way to to live
usually that's people thinking
that their inner critic demands it or
their parents demand it obviously the
bigger your audience the more you you
can fall into thinking that like there
are hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of people who who demand it but of
course that also gives you the power to
do something very
helpful and liberating for those people
when you break the fourth wall or
whatever and point out that it isn't
like that yeah yeah the other one i
always get is the morning routine people
will send me on instagram like what
steve can you tell us your morning
routine yeah i can almost imagine them
at home like sending the dm and being
sat there with their notepad ready for
my response and i'm like honestly i
sometimes i get out but at 11.
sometimes i don't sleep so i end up
getting i bet at one sometimes you know
i'll get out six there's no green juice
for me there's no yoga there's no
continual meditation or run or whatever
right it's a sloppy mess the whole
process the whole process of me waking
up is a really sloppy mess i'm trying to
improve i bring people here that talk
about morning routines it still doesn't
seem to work
but um but despite of that yeah i'm
happy my businesses have gone well i've
managed to achieve my ambitions despite
of my total imperfection in most key
areas that the happiness industry would
assert
because they need to sell you complex
things or else why would you buy
if if the truth is that
you're going to be imperfect and that's
okay maybe i'm okay you said that if
that's the truth it's hard to sell you
it but that's the truth as i know it and
that's why i enjoy these conversations
one thing i did talk about there was
procrastination
and this is a topic where which i think
honestly plagues people into feeling
like they are inadequate yeah if i make
a video on my instagram about
procrastination it will outperform
everything relationships perform the
best okay number two right is anything
with the title progress maybe i'll title
this video about procrastination and
it'll do really well yeah why do people
procrastinate
well they watch those videos presumably
while they should be getting on with
their getting on with the working
questions right that's that's that's
probably going to subscribe
procrastination videos are really
popular one level there's lots of
different reasons fear of failure fear
of success fear of all sorts of
different things but but at the deep
level
i make the argument anyway
you don't want to feel
what it feels like to be
limited and imperfect and so if you hold
on to a project if you keep it in your
mind in the world of fantasy
it can stay perfect it can be later that
you're going to do this great thing
any action that actually brings things
into the world involves a confrontation
with your limitations maybe you're not
going to
have the talent for it maybe it's not
going to be well received maybe it's
going to be too complicated if i'm
trying to write a chapter of a book
like the stakes are high for me because
i want it to go well but i don't know
that it is going to go well i want it to
be well received but i don't know that
it will be well received
so much nicer to just spend that time
doing something kind of
pointless and
you know scrolling around or whatever
because
yeah because i don't have to have
confront my limitations and what i want
to try to convey in that topic in in in
this book anyway i think is to say look
bringing anything into the world
studying for any um
qualification doing any kind of creative
work like
launching any kind of business like it
the the imperfection is guaranteed like
you definitely aren't going to get to
bring it into the world in in exactly in
tune with your fantasy and everyone is
in the same boat
and this is completely unavoidable and
baked in
[Music]
so you might as well do it right because
it's like people i think people they get
caught up in themselves they think well
i'm going to make fool of myself or i'm
going to let myself down or i'm going to
let my friends or my parents down but
it's like no
the imperfection
the fact that it will stumble and not be
everything you dreamed it could have
been
that ship has sailed like that's just
for everyone so now can we just move
forward and do our imperfect things and
lots of them will turn out to be
uh
you know fantastic things but they will
all be imperfect because because that's
what it is to to bring things into the
world as a human being knowing that
having written a
chapter in your book called becoming a
better procrastinator
do you still procrastinate
yes um
i've always i always feel like my my
point about that i get asked this
question and i'm always like look you
got to compare me with who i was before
not with this perfect person because i
am not that perfect person but i am a
lot better at it than i was um
[Music]
yeah and what where i stumble
on that is not so much anymore
with the idea that it's got to be
like
perfect standard because if you spend a
few years as a journalist you get that
sort of beating out of you right because
like deadlines come deadlines come you
just got to send the thing in and you
stop thinking after a while that you're
that your glorious prose has got to be
perfect you can't let it out of your
sight until it's perfect because it's
just never how it works where i still
run into trouble is that i do feel this
urge to feel in control of all the
things that are going on in my life and
all things going on in my
work so it's very tempting for me
to say um
you know i've got to write that really
important thing or i've got to think
through this really important thing but
first i'm going to
make sure that all my inboxes are
under control and then i'm going better
do all that admin about finances that
i'd left that i'd left and i better sort
of
and then you before you know it it's
like better like rearrange my desk so
that all the all the pens are
straightened up whatever displacement
activities things that make me feel
more
in control of my world but actually
don't move the things that i care about
forward the most and i'm getting better
on that too but that's the thing that's
where the the struggle is
for me i will definitely spend like
long periods of time
getting my ducks in a row and clearing
the decks and i write in the book about
how you've really got to try and fight
this urge to clear the decks because
they will never be clear right so you've
got to you've got to just get on with
things but uh but yeah
work in progress for sure that's a very
honest answer and i'm glad to hear that
you and me both
quick one for many years people have
been asking for a coffee flavored huel
and quite recently he'll release the
iced coffee caramel flavor of their um
ready-to-drink heels and i've just
become hooked on it over the last couple
of weeks i've been on a really
interesting journey with huel which i've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast i started with the berry
ready to drinks then i moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now i'm balanced between
them both i drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink i've got really
into the iced coffee caramel um flavor
of heels ready to drink and now i'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as i said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
smash here so check it out let me know
what you think on social media i see all
of your tags and instagram posts and
tweets about you back to the podcast
in that chapter about procrastination
you talk a lot about focus as well in
this idea of avoiding your middling
priorities
which i thought was really good advice
so could you talk a little bit about the
importance of avoiding middling
priorities certainly the the the story
that dramatizes this is this idea that
some people may have heard about it's
attributed to warren buffett but i think
probably it didn't come from warren
buffett people often just take wise
sayings and say that warren buffett will
do that with me
christ
it's warren buffett
buddha and confucius
so hopefully you know he's about you as
well right yes right right right but he
is supposed
buffett is supposed to been asked like
how do you decide what to prioritize in
life and to have replied that you should
make a list of your top 25 goals in life
and
order them numerically from 1 to 25
and then take the top five on that list
and really focus on them in your life
and take the next 20 and avoid them like
the plague
because they are the ones that you care
about enough to let them distract you
from the from the top five but not
the ones that you're that are easy to
let go of because you don't really care
about them right they belong in this
middle zone
whether or not that exercise is a useful
exercise the the principle here
i think is that you have to sort of be
especially wary of of
claims on your attention and your time
that
do matter a bit
but just not as much as the things that
you care about the most it's very easy
to um people talk all the time about the
importance of learning to say no right
but people often i think in the there's
a subtext there they think what that
means is if you just learn to say no to
all the stuff you don't want to do you
can spend your time doing stuff you do
want to do
but i quote actually elizabeth gilbert
the writer in the book saying like no
it's way harder than that you have to
say no to things that you do want to do
because
there are more things that matter
than you have time for so middling
priorities are you know
that friendship that yeah it's fine you
know it's nice when you meet up with
that person but it's not
neither of you getting that much out of
it and it's taking another hour away
from
i don't know your partner your child
your best friend you know definitely
sort of
work projects that sort of
yeah you can do them you could handle
that it might make you a little bit of
money or you know whatever but it's just
not it's not the number one thing takes
quite a lot to resist those because they
are
they're not unimportant they're just not
important enough
and it feels like um
more is more but as the phrase goes in
this context less is more you i i've
observed that in my life anyway if you
if you want to be successful in business
then focusing on one as opposed to
having three startups is much more much
better but some people will brag about
how many businesses they run or how many
things they do as if they believe that
that makes them more more valuable
they'll brag about how many friends they
have as opposed to the quality of them
and it tends to be the case that that
phrase less is more is is true in the
sense of
focusing on less things gives you much
more meaning and depth in life and
that's ultimately what's what matters
yeah and actually i think it's probably
the way to accomplish more things as
well right it's it's um
so
one thing that i've found i i can't talk
on the level of businesses launched but
only on the level of uh you know
articles and books written is the degree
to which i can do things sequentially
and train myself to do one big thing at
a time and wait till it's finished
before you move to the next one takes a
lot takes kind of guts to do it because
it feels better to have a finger in
every part once but
to the extent that i can do that to that
extent i get more of those things done
um
because you make most of them wait
you focus on one
you do it and then it's finished and
then you bring the next one in and you
do that um
it's so tempting to sort of dissipate
your energies because i think it makes
you feel we're back to the same idea
right makes you feel limitless it makes
you feel like
you can wrap your arms around the whole
world stops people in the case of my
work it stops people pestering you
because like where's that thing you said
you'd do and
it's very nice to live in that world of
um of sort of multitasking and
multi-projects but it's not the most
effective way to
get the things done
yeah i i'm struggling with that i think
for sure and
i think
i think as well when you've got um
when you've got more opportunities
like i get a lot of a lot of people
sending me a lot of things to do these
days a lot of things that i could do it
becomes an even greater and more
important skill to master so the amount
of like we had one day last week where
they're like every
journalist across these multiple
newspapers wants to speak to you about
this i made this donation
and
there's part of me that goes oh yeah
that's you know i'll do all of these tv
things that day but then of course it
comes at the cost of something else and
we and we never really focus on the cost
right it seems like yeah and that's kind
of the curse i have in my mind sometimes
is i'm too focused on the benefit of
doing the thing as if
you know which is basically the premise
of your book that like
as if my time was unlimited yeah but
yeah you know it's like i was i remember
reading about this thing which
has weirdly stayed in my mind for many
years
this idea that they believe humans can
only juggle a certain amount of balls
because of the physics of a ball going
up and then the speed in which one could
possibly move so they think it's 14 and
nobody's been able to break the world
record ever
is that the record the 14 balls no one's
ever been able to juggle more than 14
balls and and that record has held
because of the physics of the balls
going up and the way that they would
collide if you made it 15 and that made
me think there is a physical limitation
to the amount of balls we can physically
juggle as humans and the balls you pick
up come at the expense of the ones you
don't yeah and that's i've tried to keep
remember that that i have to pick my 14
balls in life hopefully not [ __ ] 14 i
can probably do two but i have to pick
my balls in life and realize that every
one i pick is at the expense of another
and even looking at you know i write in
my book i really love waffles but i also
like want to have a six pack
i can only pick one you know
right right really you know that's a
metaphor but like i have to choose which
one's important and it's the same with
cheating
some people might like having sex but
they also might like having a
relationship and you have to realize
that if you want to be in a faithful
relationship it comes at the cost of
something and um
right no and i think that you know we
yes we spend so much effort trying to
avoid thinking about costs or trying to
avoid
incurring them but again
there's something
freeing about seeing that you are always
incurring costs that every decision to
spend an hour doing anything is the
decision to not spend it doing other
things that
you know
every path you choose you're you're
declining to choose all these other
paths
it's painful because it means that like
loss is built in to
living a human life but it's also
like it's so unavoidable
like there's nothing that can be done
about that that's just built into being
finite so in a way like
we can relax about that actually if
there wasn't cost though things wouldn't
be special like right yes forever
if i could have the best of both worlds
then the one i choose wouldn't have it
you know scarcity adds value they say so
totally and i mean there's been there's
there's like philosophical work going
back on like would you actually want to
be immortal uh
if you could no and i agree yeah i don't
think you would because i think as i uh
writes in the book like if you were
immortal
the answer to the question
should i do x with my day today would
always just be who cares
like because if you didn't do it today
you could do it on any number of other
days
to the
uh stretching off into infinity so i
think absolutely uh it's not pleasant to
confront our finichu but life would have
no
meaning if it went if it didn't stop you
write about watermelons in your book
oh yeah chapter five is about the
watermelon problem
the famous buzzfeed watermelon this was
like what five years ago now two
journalists from buzzfeed put rubber
bands around the watermelon and they
just kept adding rubber bands
uh things like 600 and something rubber
bands before the watermelon just
exploded
that was the end of the facebook live
but the point that i'm using it to make
is that you know millions of people
watch that
and i'm not like
i don't think there's anything terrible
with spending
an hour of your life watching people put
rubber bands around a watermelon but but
they didn't choose to watch it that's a
it's a very clear example of the way in
which especially in the sort of
attention economy that we live in now
your attention is incredibly important
because what you pay attention to
just is your life right what over the
course of your life whatever you paid
attention to
it's just
it's just what your life was
and yet it's very easily
uh hijackable um
and
and you know nobody who ended up
watching that that hour got up that
morning thinking um
what i'd really like to do today is uh
spend an hour put it watching people put
rubber bands around a watermelon so it's
just really the the question of
distraction the question of how we
steward our attention and again if you
want a break in the middle of the day
and someone's doing some stunt involving
a watermelon fine
right but but just
bringing consciousness to that fact that
when we pay attention to things we are
paying very literally with
little chunks of our of our life have
you found any practical ways to make
yourself less distracted by such
compelling videos
there's really two parts to this i think
one is especially in the modern era
right one is
the source of the distraction so
definitely like i don't have social
media on my
phone i do that on a
i do that on a laptop exclusively um
[Music]
i've i've sort of have a sort of ever
shifting and never never perfectly
observed set of personal rules about
like when i will turn to my email and
when i will turn to the internet and
when i will be
trying to be sort of offline and focused
on
on
writing and thinking
but the other side of it i think is
is the distractibility not just the sort
of
not the things that are reaching out to
grab our attention but the fact that we
kind of go along willingly with this
stuff and again you know it's just my
one thesis but i think the reason that
we're doing that is because it's much
more comfortable than focusing on hard
stuff focusing on hard stuff is is
is unpleasant sometimes because it
brings us into contact with our
limitations and then
distraction is much nicer thing to do uh
with that time because it doesn't
so really a big part of this for me and
it's been definitely a slow gradual
thing it's not a sort of uh one clever
trick or something is just to expect
a certain amount of discomfort in things
that matter right just to sort of
just to expect that
writing i keep using this example
because it's personal to me but like
that it's
like it feels difficult uh cal newport
who wrote the book deep work and digital
minimalism who's very good on this has
this argument that like
what people call writer's block that's
just the feeling of writing right
because it's a hard thing to do and
sometimes you might get into flow great
but most of the time it's probably going
to be a question of like
it's like a little bit hard and the
analogy that people always use is with
weightlifting right i mean you don't
expect if it's you don't expect that to
feel
non-non-uncomfortable not that i have
great experience of it but like you
don't
there are certain areas where things
where sort of growth
involves discomfort and we're okay with
that and then there are other areas
often involving
cognitive activities where we we're
somehow deeply offended that it feels a
bit difficult to do it but no it does
the other thing that i always think is
extraordinarily difficult is really
listening to another person right it
never really gets super easy that i
think especially in relationships right
to sort of to really concentrate on what
someone is saying and not just to be
thinking oh but then when when they're
finished this is what i'm going to say
it's it takes effort and if you're
if if your response to that feeling of
effort is like i can't feel effort it
must be easy then it's going to be much
more tempting to just be like checking
your phone when you should be listening
or something so just a bit of a
willingness to experience mild
discomfort i think it's kind of a
superpower
yeah and obviously
there's a lot of social narratives that
kind of point to it as being a failure
like you're right even the phrase
writer's block
the word block doesn't feel like
very natural it feels like there's
something that must be got a disorder
right yeah yeah
yeah yeah and a lot it's so funny
because you said at the start of this
some of these new inventions are really
holding us back like words
and vocabulary like there's so many of
them even i talk a lot about in my book
the idea of finding your passion there's
so many like
things um hidden within that phrase
first you have to go in search of it
because of the word find
so people go they go off in search of
this thing that they think they can find
it alludes to the fact that it's
singular
because the word passion is singular
so i'm looking for a easter egg
somewhere which i need to go and search
and find and if i don't find it that i'm
a failure and much of the the messages i
get in my dm's as i've said before are
kids that are feeling inadequate and
like they're a failure because they
haven't found their passion when if you
say well maybe maybe it's not something
that you have to go in search of
necessarily maybe there's more than one
yep it can be a really liberating thing
and i think words generally are really
constrained and they cause people a ton
of like are you in love my mom comes
home i'm you know i'm dating someone she
goes is it love immediately after my
brain scrambles around trying to figure
out what i feel is the same as the
definition that she feels because i said
i loved peanut butter but this is
different yeah it's like and that for
and also if it gets a binary response
yes or no yeah makes you so
self-conscious that you can't actually
give yourself to the experience that's
reminding me of um
when i became a
father like literally
95 of people who i interacted with who
were parents themselves already would
would say um
oh you should you should really savor
these early months with a newborn baby
it's so special you should really savor
it and this is true it is incredibly
special you should savor it
but all it did to me was have me
thinking like oh my goodness am i am i
savoring this in the right way am i and
then of course
you're certainly not savoring it in that
time because you're just like lost in
your head and it's like
this yeah absolutely it's just it's
another it's another example of it right
yeah yeah and i guess the antidote is to
liberate yourself from
the expectation of like words and
phrases and
expect social expectations that you
should feel and act a certain way and be
able to answer certain questions
yeah or just to understand that like you
know
yeah things are complicated and you only
they sort of congeal over time and you
sometimes you only understand things in
the rearview mirror and uh you just sort
of have to navigate intuitively you
probably do know
when you're in a relationship you don't
know if it's love you probably do know
if it
feels like it's got forward motion or if
it feels terribly stagnant or if it feel
you know you can you can sort of intuit
these things even if you can't slot
these them into
these kind of rigid categories yeah
i i might get this quite wrong but when
you're talking about c cognitive
behavioral therapy and in fact we can
achieve a form of which may be better
than cognitive behavioral therapy of
that therapy with like self-analysis in
various ways and for me this podcast and
the diary that i had to keep originally
when it first started to do it and also
this obligation i have to make content
for the world has been one of the
greatest forms of like therapy i've ever
encountered um and i i always
i think it's like one of the
unappreciated ways to
arrive at self-awareness overcome your
own [ __ ] and
yeah which is which is having to write
yeah to think and having to try and find
the truth in your own experience yeah
can you relate to that no totally and i
for me i mean there's lots of research
about how writing down your personal
problems for example is incredibly like
journaling it works and it's proven to
work um it's not necessarily because you
come up with solutions although that can
happen it's because you end up you sort
of have to take this third person stance
on your own
mental contents and you have to do that
for sure if you're trying to package it
in some form that other people can um
can benefit from or can understand so
writing for an audience is absolutely an
example of that um
there's something incredibly powerful in
seeing your
issues your interests whatever from the
perspective of
another person i think it's related to
that thing about how so often in life
you know
our friends can see what what we need to
do or
what what's needed in our lives a bit
more clearly than
than we can because you sort of um
[Music]
you can't see the wood from the for the
trees inside your own head but but they
can be like no very obviously you need
to do this and then this yeah so it's a
little bit of that uh of that effect as
well and how you can always give better
advice than you live by no absolutely
tell me about it
um
the consequences of having this highly
efficient
productivity focused life
you see it in people you were talking
earlier about the the great innovators
of the world that manage to focus on a
set of priorities but when you ask these
people if they're happy like elon musk
if he's happy no i know but he thinks
elon musk is happy
no and i think he said in the rogan
interview that you wouldn't like to be
me you wouldn't like to write ahead um
but we still seem to pursue
that over what we think will make us
happy any well what where what what will
clearly make us happy anyway
i think that uh all of us
have
something inside us that we're sort of
here this doesn't sound too supernatural
that we're sort of here to express and
to
to put out into the world i think the
it gets complicated because some people
i don't want to accuse elon musk of this
but
i think it's probably very often true of
certain kind of very driven people
it's not just that they're sort of
trying to bring their gift into the
world it's an odd and not necessarily
helpful way of trying to sort out
certain like psychological issues they
have so they feel that they have to
achieve a certain amount because
they were not um you know given
sufficient unconditional love by their
parents so they need it from the world
or they
feel that um yeah they need to justify
their existence in in some way
and then it gets hard to know when to
stop it gets hard to tell the difference
between success and things that are
truly bringing you happiness but at the
same time right you don't want to
it's important to
to not suggest i think that the the
ideal
is to be
for everyone is to be so completely
chilled out that all you would want to
do is lie in a hammock on a on a beach
and sort of
not
create things in in one way or another
that might be appropriate for for some
people but there is this fear when i
talk about this stuff and write about
this stuff of like oh
wouldn't it lead you to just think well
why do anything you know what wouldn't
it all just lead us to be sort of
nihilists in that way um uh and i don't
think so for that reason but i also
think uh
like let's cross that bridge when we
come to it we're already we're all so
driven and so sort of um trying to get
more and more and more done but there's
not a huge risk yet of us becoming so
zen about all these things that we kind
of stop achieving entirely i i pondered
that a lot in my life um this idea that
because one of the things you said
earlier was maybe i'm okay this kind of
realization that maybe i am already
enough yeah maybe none of these goals
are going to increase my
value maybe even if i become a
multi-millionaire steve bartlett is just
going to be worth one steve bartlett
still
um
i had i pondered that for
when i became a millionaire right when i
was my company listed on the stock
market
and i thought well this doesn't feel any
different in fact the anti-climax makes
me feel pretty bad like the expectation
that i was going to feel
you know like i was more worthy that the
the anti-climax of that has had made me
feel worse
and then
asking myself the question well if i am
already enough then what's the point in
striving for more and my conclusive my
conclusion on all of this
ponderance was that
realizing that i'm enough is actually
the foundation for like real ambition
and the minute when i was when i was
insecure enough to believe that money or
a lamborghini might make me more i was
striving for things that weren't my real
ambitions they were social ambitions and
the minute you realize you're enough and
that lamborghini isn't going to do it
then you start re re-planning your
ambitions and go you know what i
actually love doing is piano right
hanging out with my niece right so that
that feeling that that i am enough
is the foundation for real ambition
totally yeah no i think that's a great
that's such a good way of putting it i
mean i the way i've sometimes thought
about this is like
sort of ambition and achievement and
creation they don't have to be the thing
you're doing the thing that you need to
do in order to get somewhere they can be
the thing you do just to express yes the
fact that it's great to be here and you
they're great to have these skills and
these opportunities um
[Music]
i'm not religious but there is a this
idea in christianity that i keep running
up against now because people contact me
and say have you thought about this
because it's clearly related this notion
of this notion of uh
grace that that like you don't you can't
justify yourself by
your
works in the world right you can't sort
of achieve salvation by what you do
but you also don't in this model anyway
you don't need to achieve it either
because you're already justified in the
eyes of god if you're a religious person
and so the reason that you do things
like this from the reason that you then
do stuff in the world
is
is again it's just like yeah it's it's
for the it's an act of like
glorification or worship right or for as
we were saying like just expressing
the fact that it's great to be able to
do these things and like
hey you could never been born you know
you so it's not a reason to not do
things it's that it's that you're not
doing them to try to justify yourself
in the eyes of the world
or
if you're religious you know be in the
eyes of god whatever but
it doesn't mean you don't do things it
just means you do them from a different
motivation which is like hey i get to do
these things that's great you know i i
feel like these existential thinkers are
somewhat tortured
so yes yeah do you relate to that
oh sure i mean i think you know um
there's a philosopher
uh who died recently brian mcgee who um
talks about the distinction between
people who sort of have philosophical
problems and don't and what he means is
that like
from the age of like five he can
remember
lying on a in a field looking up at the
sky and thinking like
well it can't
it can't be that the universe stops
somewhere but it also can't be that it
goes on forever
like what and and yeah and saying that
there are people who are sort of
troubled by these things in some
real personal way
and then there are people who are not
troubled by those things and they have
i mean
they may be very intelligent and deep
people but they don't have these kind of
like
hold on like what what what's it all
about like was it anyway i'm i'm one of
the people who does and it sounds like
you are too uh but yeah there would be
something nice to not to not be perhaps
in your book you say that we're addicted
to the speed of life
is that true and why is that an
addiction
i'm i'm talking there about
the sort of acceleration of the culture
the fact that everything you know
moves so fast that we're able to do so
many things so much more quickly
travel communicate uh
cook food you know then we than we once
could and how and why that like it's a
if you stop and think about it it's
really weird that all that technology
and all that acceleration has not left
us feeling um more relaxed and chilled
out right because it saves time
um
the world that has
747s in it and microwaves in it and the
internet in it or by right to feel
much calmer
because it's all this time is say but of
course it doesn't have that effect like
it does have has that effect on nobody
um it makes everybody feel
more impatient and rushed um and i think
that the reason
that the the frame of addiction makes
sense i'm drawing on the work of a
therapist called stephanie brown who's
who was herself
an alcoholic got sober with aa
then started being a therapist to in
silicon valley to various people in the
sort of first.com boom around to like
2000's
and and seeing in them this trait in
their addiction to urge what she called
their addiction to urgency their
addiction to speed that reminded her
very much of
of
her youthful experiences as an alcoholic
namely that you're sort of
life speeds up you feel overwhelmed you
think that going faster it has got to be
the solution right if you go even faster
then you can cope with all this rush of
incoming information incoming
opportunities whatever it is um so you
go faster but then you find that
actually
that's just increased the the speed of
everything and now you need to go faster
still and it's a sort of it's a spiral
and you crash
there's controversy about talking about
addiction whether it
should be kept as a sort of strictly
kind of medical idea
but
i think that's really
it resonates with me because i feel like
it's very tempting in this in this world
that feels like there's so much stuff to
stay on top of and it moves at such
tempo there is this notion that like the
only solution is for you to go even
faster than it is to be able to
encompass all of that and this is this
is not going to work uh because
you are never going to be able to you
know there is an infinite supply right
there's an effectively infinite number
of emails you could receive
demands your boss could make
opportunities you could pursue
businesses you could stop whatever
so getting faster at going through an
infinite supply
you don't get to the end of that because
it's infinite so stephanie brown's
advice to her
clients and i think it's it's it's very
useful is that
all of us who are sort of moving at this
speed need to experiment a little bit
with like what it feels like to just
slow down to the speed that things take
and say you know what i'm i'm if i'm
going to read this novel
and it takes my time and it takes
i need to look read slowly and focus i'm
just going to like yeah it's not going
to feel great at first right because we
are wired for racing through things
and it doesn't feel great at first but
but it is a path to a much deeper kind
of engagement
with the world one of the things i do in
the book is i write about um
this exercise that i did that
is recommended by an art historian at
harvard university who i went to
interview who she has all her students
choose a painting and go and look at it
for three hours
like
sit on a little bench whatever
and just look at that painting for three
hours take notes if you want but you're
not allowed to get up
and
she knows it's like it's
completely insane for almost anybody
today to envisage doing something like
that for for three hours
but that's why she that's why she
suggests it and you know for the first
hour it's incredibly uncomfortable
because you're not in charge anymore you
can't race through the day in the way
that you were accustomed to
doing but it is so
useful because
getting through that discomfort to what
lies on the other side
is
is so empowering i think patience is
really a kind of a superpower in the
modern in the modern world and in the
context of the painting what happens is
you literally see things in the painting
that you haven't seen in the first 45
minutes i mean it's it's bizarre in the
context of
work creative work
business i think it's more just that
like when everyone is racing as fast as
they are today there's actually real
power
in being able to resist that and let
things take the time they take and think
about something for a few more days if
that's what it takes like you actually
can
have more success that way as well as
feel less like a headless chicken is
there a role of impatience though is
there a role somewhere in life for
impatience
it depends how you define it right so in
the book i'm talking about in patients
as wanting things to go faster than you
can have them go so then i'd say like no
there's never any
even if you're sort of um
driving somebody to the hospital because
they're going into labor or something
right i mean it's like
you should do that really fast you
should be urgent you should you should
prioritize that and you should you know
go as you should drive as fast as is
practical but even then it's probably
not worth
feeling frustrated that
you're
stuck in
traffic or something right i mean it's
so if impatience is that kind of
frustration
at the fact that you have limited
control over how fast the world goes how
fast something happens then no i mean
it's it's just wild right we now are
much more impatient like if a web page
takes five seconds to load like you can
feel it it's ridiculous
but if somebody says yeah i'll put that
stuff in the mail and you'll get it in
three days you're like that's fine
right it says
okay all right the mail
the faster things get the more offensive
it is when they still only take a few
seconds like when there's a few seconds
delay um
if we're using the word in another way
to mean
uh
having a sort of
hunger for things to change in your life
or change in society you know you're not
not willing to sort of
sit around and be a
be a doormat while things
when you could change things then sure
uh i think that's a different kind of
impatience and i'm sure it has a role
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast is one of
the brands that make that transition
much much easier they are at the
forefront of british renewable ecosmart
technology and their products are really
really changing the game if you're on
youtube you can see what i'm holding in
my hand this is called the eddie right
it's the uk's number one solar powered
diverter so what is a solar diverter
it's a device for people like you and me
that means you can divert your excess
energy back into your home rather than
back into the grid which will save you
power and money it's super user friendly
and easy to install and you can control
it using the my energy app on your phone
to find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com
and um i highly recommend you check out
the eddie it's um it's a real game
changer for a product and one that i'm
going to be installing in my home soon
in your book you talk about embracing
radical incrementalism
what does that mean for you
this is the idea that there are contexts
where um
really being willing to make
progress on the basis of little and
often right
kind of gradual progress to do a tiny
bit at a time
and not kind of binging on the things
you're trying to achieve can be
really powerful um again i'm sorry to
keep coming back to writing as an
example but the the work that i'm
drawing on there from a psychologist
called robert boyce who studied um
academics who write and figured trying
to figure out like who are the ones who
actually get a ton of papers published
and a ton of books written and who are
the ones who get mired in um
like procrastination and paralysis and
he found that the really productive
people in that sphere were the ones who
made writing a um
a modest part of their
daily life right it occupied like a
couple of hours maybe as opposed to the
ones who made it into this huge thing
that then became very intimidating and
they got all sorts of like psychodramas
going on with it because
it was something they were willing to
sort of do for a little bit
leave aside come back to and i think
this applies to especially applies to
anything that is like brain work but i
think it applies to pretty much all all
kinds of endeavor right there's often a
huge benefit
in being willing
to say well i'm going to work on this
for a tiny amount of time today and i'm
going to stop even if i'm on a roll
right when my time is up i'm going to
stop
and then i'm going to come back it makes
it something that you can sustain
day after day after days if you do the
opposite of incrementalism right if you
give this if you give this sort of
absolutely center stage in your life
then if it goes well great if it doesn't
go well it becomes this kind of huge
intimidating
uh thing and i've found that you know if
i'm working on a book say
really sort of almost embarrassingly
small work days on it
regularly
done
day after day after day
so much more productive like in terms of
the actual output
deadlines though because when i wrote my
book i think this the deadline of having
to send to the publisher just hung over
me and was like forcing me to okay speak
today you have to write three
you know 3 000 words
yeah i think deadlines have their role
right and i you know i would have got
nowhere without deadlines in newspapers
because they sort of kept they sort of
helped me sort of bust through
perfectionism and stuff because it was
just literally you know it's i did these
things on a i would write these kind of
features for the guardian where i had to
like um that the idea
came to me or was given to me at uh like
10 30 in the morning and 5 pm they
needed a
two and a half thousand word researched
article you just be like okay i've just
got to do it
but
um
[Music]
in a way i'm sort of training myself out
of that now and i think that just to
make it it isn't a it's perfectly okay
and it's fine but but it but it isn't
sustainable i think that you know
that the
to really over the long haul be able to
do something
like like writing i've found requires
that i have
acquired this ability for sort of
dogged persistence rather than you know
cruising to the
to the deadline another topic that
people hate talking about or that at
least it seems to make people really
uncomfortable and i sometimes i just
bring up the conversation because i like
to see
i find the the con i find the reaction
to be really
i find the reaction to be really
fascinating is this idea which you talk
about which is that we need to embrace
our like relative irrelevance
oh yeah in the world and when i say this
to people
you can see it sometimes shattering
something in them the idea that they
don't matter
in the grand scheme of the universe they
really don't matter
what like why is what is the upside of
embracing my own irrelevance this idea
and do i matter oliver
depends what you mean by matter do i
matter in this in the grand scheme of
the universe
i don't really think any of us i think i
mean i think i mean what i'm what i want
to say about this is
if you adopt a cosmic time scale right
if you love the history of like the
cosmos or even just the planet
like no human life
uh or even anything that is done in a
human life you know almost nothing
will outlive us and the things that do
outlive us like you know people
inventing great scientific breakthroughs
or something
even then the the period that these have
been relevant if you look at the cosmos
is still like a tiny blink of an eye um
so
i think there is a sort of inbuilt bias
that most of us have not not just the
ones who are megalomaniacs but almost
all of us to to think
sort of
subliminally of history as having led up
to like tower bit of history right and
then to think of the decisions that we
take in the things that we're doing as
fundamentally the most important things
that are going on in that bit of history
and that's on some level we probably
have to right just to sort of short to
be able to like get up in the morning
it's not you can't think of yourself as
this kind of tiny pimpric of light in
the middle of
eons of
darkness of the cosmos from the big bang
to the you know to to when the universe
ends or whatever
but
actually you can really get bogged down
in that you can really be like well you
can spend a long time mined an
indecision about things because
you've built the stakes up in your head
to an enormous degree you can really
get sort of
depressed about whether you can really
have an impact on things because it has
to be something that lives for millennia
after you're gone or something and
when you realize how little most of it's
going to matter quite soon i some people
do go down that into like despair and
horror
but i think that is a reason to be like
why not
take the risk like why not do the bold
things it's like the stakes are a lot
lower than you thought the universe
doesn't really care um you don't need to
worry about whether you're fulfilling
your
purpose that the universe had laid down
for you because there kind of isn't one
and that's actually it's liberating as i
keep saying it's a reason to
it's a reason to sort of experimentally
do the things that seem to you like the
the the
the coolest
things to do then what you can do is you
can you can use a definition of
mattering according to which so much
that we do matters right because
i think it's difficult for people to
remember that like
i don't know i don't want to use a
definition of a meaningful life
that rules out
some very mundane things like caring for
a sick relative cooking nutritious meals
for your kids
making your neighborhood a slightly more
beautiful place to live in like we don't
want a definition of the meaning of
meaningful lives that says none of those
things are meaningful surely um
and so
yeah i can imagine that it's an
interesting issue for sort of people who
people who look up to you specifically
for example thinking that thinking that
it's actually like they've got to
emulate you in order to be doing
something meaningful rather than be
inspired by you which is different which
is a different point right because
actually very very
everyday mundane things
can be meaningful and it's quite
possible that the most fulfilled people
on the planet are precisely the ones you
never hear from because they're doing
low profile things and then
you know i have this theory
maybe it's maybe it's insulting to you
this theory but i have this theory that
like
the more of a public profile someone has
and i have a modest one so it supplies
to me too but like that's probably like
to that degree
is like
they're screwed up in some way because
they have some problem with not being
ordinary
and then you know the hollywood a-list
those people are probably the most
no it is i mean it definitely begets
more problems i i noticed that this week
i had a journalist email me saying that
five years ago one of your ex-employees
says your dog did a poop in the office
and you didn't pick it up and i thought
[ __ ] how
this is what my life has become
genuinely and i i was like ponder i've
been pondering it ever since i received
that email that now that like my life is
of somewhat public interest
it means everything every like
fault i might have made or didn't make
um is now i'm now gonna be like
scrutinized for and i'm now gonna have
to
justify
because if i don't then my life could be
cancelled right which is a tough bar to
live by and one i wish i didn't have to
live by to be honest but
it is fascinating because
if i had said that
you know our our own death and
irrelevance could be a motivating force
it doesn't appear on the surface that
that makes sense but i completely agree
that my own fine like the finality of my
life and my own irrelevance are two
things that liberate me from getting
caught up in the idea that a comment on
instagram matters or how my hair is
matters and that hopefully liberates me
enough to go in the pursuit of things
that do provide me with my own
subjective meaning in life so yeah and
that help other people and lift other
people up right it's not that when i
talk i talk in the book about cosmic
insignificance and i sort of mean that
right it's like from the perspective of
the cosmos no it doesn't matter but that
doesn't mean that it doesn't matter it
can matter to
people here today you know
one of the things we do in this podcast
a long-standing tradition is we ask
people
who've just come in to leave a question
for the next guest so the last guest
leaves a question for the next guest
before i do that in the back of your
book you you pun you leave the reader
five questions for them to ponder i
wanted to ask you one of your own
questions
from the five that you left
so i'm gonna go for question four in
which areas of your life are you still
holding back until you feel like you
know what you're doing
yeah this is definitely one that speaks
to me i mean obviously i obviously i put
the questions in because they speak to
me but like this is this difficulty that
i think we all have but i really have
had with realizing that like on some
level everyone is winging it
so it sort of speaks to imposter
syndrome and things like that and and
and
and not feeling not launching into
things until you feel that you're
that you're
ready recently since the book was out
i've been giving more sort of talks and
speeches than i ever have done in my
life before and um
you know i've sort of been forced into
not holding back on that because the
invitations come in and i say yes to
them and then it's like oh my god i got
to do this that is something where i
feel perpetually un
ready um
and
if it was up to me
i would uh
probably have left it you know some more
i mean it was up to me but if i'd felt
that it was up to me i would have left
it some more years to sort of get really
good at doing that
and uh
uh you know and and i
and i'm not i'm not ready but it seems
to be going okay um
i kind of evaded that question by by
saying by by giving you an example of
something where i'm not holding back
because i'm actually doing them but um
i think that answer was really good does
it count no it does it does count and i
it really speaks to because i also
believe that had been of your own choice
to get really good before you do it you
probably never would have done it right
which is what most people it's like the
trap of the mind that i will launch my
business when
i have some time or i will launch it
when i am i've learned something but we
never
there's never a perfect time so
unfortunately we're forced into picking
an imperfect time yeah and now is always
an imperfect time so i always try and
employ people on that basis to do the
thing that they think
the perfect day will enable um
now to ask you the question that our
previous guest did leave
oh
okay so i never read it until until i
opened the book
um they have good handwriting so i can
read this one do you do enough to keep
learning
uh
that's a very good question um no i
there are definitely i i
i definitely aspire to make more space
in my days for especially for reading
why
uh
[Music]
because it gets squeezed out by
by
doing things related to writing and
books it actually gets hard to sort of
keep that
section of
of time for just sort of the exploration
of
uh
ideas in in that way on the other hand i
want to say that things like uh
becoming a parent even things like
moving back from new york to the uk like
there are certain ways in which you
learn that are not like
book based learning and you just sort of
are dragged forwards in your education
whether you like it or not and i think
in those ways it's more a question of
seeing what you're being taught
and that you are learning than than
needing to make more time
for learning that's an interesting
question but also in your being pulled
into speaking more and all that yeah
absolutely new skills that you have to
sort of you're doing yeah no totally but
i it is but it is just the honest answer
is it is something that i
i don't feel sort of
satisfied about in terms of my
the apportionment of my
of my time what about stuff like this
and coming here today this is i love
this kind of conversation and um and i
think obviously you learn from it
completely um
but uh so i think what i'm talking about
is sort of
yeah i guess it is the i guess it is
exposing myself to
new avenues
of thinking that are not sort of jumping
off from things that i've already
thought about yeah i don't know yeah i
this kind of conversation is great
well thank you and thank you for writing
such a brilliant book one that i feel
like is going to liberate people from a
lot of [ __ ] that's holding them back
in many many ways from stress to anxiety
to feelings of inadequacy because we're
trying to live up to a social
expectation that is unachievable and i
think
i know for a fact that based on the
questions i get asked a lot in my dms
that my audience should read this book
so i implore them to do so because also
the way that you write is from such a
nuanced human perspective which is um
avoiding the like cheap answers or the
binary um answers to some of the big
questions about life productivity
efficiency and everything
that plagues us in the modern world so
thank you for writing such a great book
thank you for your time as well and yeah
it's been an absolute pleasure chatting
to you thank you so much that's so kind
of you to say i've really enjoyed it
thank you
oh
[Music]
bye